ya he hablado de campos vectoriales y lo
que quiero hacer aquí es hablar sobre
una circunstancia especial en donde se
presentan así que imaginemos que estamos
en el plano coordenada y digamos que
dibujo un montón de gotitas digamos de
agua y que éstas van a empezar a fluir
de alguna forma como podríamos describir
este flujo de forma matemática bueno en
cada punto las partículas se mueven de
alguna forma así que por ejemplo por
aquí se mueven digamos hacia abajo y
hacia la izquierda y aquí por ejemplo se
mueven demasiado rápido verdad por
ejemplo por aquí se están moviendo un
poco más lento y lo que quisieras hacer
es digamos asignar un vector en cada
punto del espacio y un atributo de la
forma en la que fluye digamos este
líquido y esto no necesariamente es
obvio verdad pero si nos fijamos en cada
punto del espacio digamos por aquí
entonces cada vez que una partícula pasa
por ahí
digamos va a tener más o menos la misma
velocidad así que podríamos pensar que a
lo largo del tiempo esa velocidad podría
cambiar y a veces lo hace verdad un
montón de veces hay ciertos fluidos cuya
velocidad depende del tiempo verdad pero
para algunos casos digamos para justo
este punto en el espacio cualquier
partícula que pase
digamos por ese punto tendrá el mismo
vector velocidad por ejemplo por aquí
podría ser que vaya digamos hacia arriba
mientras que por ejemplo aquí tenemos un
vector muy pequeño que va hacia abajo
verdad pongamos nuevamente la animación
y si imaginamos haciendo esto para todos
los distintos puntos en el espacio
asignando un vector para describir el
movimiento digamos de cada partícula de
este fluido en cada punto distinto
entonces lo que obtenemos al final es un
campo vectorial y esto de aquí digamos
es un dibujo un poquito más claro de lo
que tenemos verdad como mencioné en el
vídeo anterior es como un digamos que
estos vectores no sean dibujados a
escala verdad lo único que tendremos es
una misma longitud para todos pero al
menos nos da una digamos una idea de la
dirección y aquí podríamos ver que cada
partícula está fluyendo digamos más o
menos siguiendo ese vector así que y
esto no es sólo una buena forma de
los flujos de los líquidos sino que
también vamos en sentido contrario es
una buena forma de entender los campos
vectoriales en sí mismos así que a veces
digamos nos podrían dar un nuevo campo
vectorial y al menos ya tenemos una
intuición de cómo va el asunto cómo
interpretarlo qué propiedades especiales
podría tener y de hecho es bastante útil
verdad incluso si si no se refiere
exactamente a un fluído podríamos
imaginar que que sí y pensar que todas
las partículas y podríamos pensar cómo
es que se mueven digamos en este espacio
por ejemplo en este caso particular si
corremos la animación y dejamos que las
partículas se muevan digamos siguiendo
los vectores no hay un cambio en la
densidad verdad en ningún punto vamos a
tener un montón de partículas que se van
concentrando o un montón de partículas
que se van alejando entre sí digamos que
más o menos se mantiene constante y esto
resulta ser que tiene un significado
matemático verdad y lo veremos más
adelante cuando estudiamos un concepto
llamado divergencia ahora por ejemplo
por aquí tenemos este campo vectorial y
podríamos tratar
como cómo se comporta y es bastante útil
pensar digamos en un fluído que está
siendo empujado hacia afuera desde todos
lados verdad 10 y digamos que de alguna
forma está disminuyendo la densidad
alrededor de este centro verdad y eso
también tiene una un significado
matemático que también podría llevarte a
plantearte otras preguntas por ejemplo
si el flujo de este líquido con el que
empezamos en el vídeo
digamos uno podría preguntarse si a lo
mejor está rotando alrededor de algunos
puntos en este caso podría uno
preguntarse si va en sentido horario o
en dirección contraria verdad si a lo
mejor esto podría tener un significado
matemático y de hecho parece ser que el
mismo número de partículas que hay en
esta área más o menos se mantiene
constante verdad solo que se están
saliendo un poco de este lado que podría
implicar esto para la función que
representa todo este campo vectorial y
bueno veremos más adelante un poco este
tema especialmente cuando hablemos de la
divergencia
el rotacional pero aquí simplemente
quise darte digamos una calentadita de
lo que vamos a visualizar en funciones
multi variables